there are few evil characters who
delight in their villainy more than
Springfield's resident billionaire
industrialist Charles Montgomery burns
and today we're looking at the worst
things that mr. burns has ever done in
the long history of the Simpsons in one
of his most diabolical and high-profile
acts of Bond level villainy mr. burns
once constructed a giant disk designed
to cast the entire town of Springfield
in shadow for 24 hours per day in effect
the plan was to force Springfield to
rely on electricity supplied by his
nuclear power plant rather than natural
sunlight the act proved to be the
catalyst for the infamous who shot mr.
burns two-part mystery that saw the
entire town outraged by burns for plenty
of other reasons earlier in the episode
the town turned on him after he tapped
an oil well beneath Springfield
Elementary causing the school to lose
funding and the town to be plagued by
environmental disaster the Sun blocking
plan however was so vile that even
Smithers broke rank and had to walk away
from his life with burns I I don't want
any part of this project it's
unconscionably fiendish pebble net
suffer your insubordination and after
announcing his nefarious plan to the
entire town who are now armed to the
teeth burns might have thought he'd
crossed the threshold from infamy to
invincibility but a swift shot from an
unlikely town's person put an end to
that perception still burns blocking the
Sun remains among his most high-profile
acts of villainy it showed that he was
okay with the entire town wanting him
dead if it meant a few more bucks in his
wallet when the Simpsons returned for
its seventh season the finale of the who
shot mr. burns two-parter revealed that
it wasn't the grand villainous plan to
block out Springfield son or even any of
his other considerable acts of greed
that got him shot instead it wasn't even
more Craven and petty Act mr. burns
straight-up tried to take candy from a
baby
after appearing to conquer the Sun burns
felt even more invincible and entitled
to do whatever he pleased in his case
that meant stealing a lollipop from
Maggie Simpson unfortunately for him he
was unaware that his pistol was
precariously placed in its holster and
in the old man's struggle with the baby
the gun went off into his chest giving
him some much-needed comeuppance in the
episode the trouble with trillions it's
revealed that after World War Two
President Harry Truman minted a one
trillion dollar bill in an effort to
reconstruct post-war Europe
the US government then tasked a spry
young mr. burns with flying the money to
Europe surprise surprise it never
arrived
obviously stealing an incomprehensible
amount of money meant to help people
after one of the most devastating pieces
of human history alone has got to be one
of mr. burns worst acts but wait there's
more after Homer helps discover that
burn still has the bill
the FBI burst in to arrest him but burns
manages to escape by fleeing the country
the second part of his escape plan
buying a tiny little Caribbean island he
found on a map unfortunately that Island
happens to be Cuba which some will note
is kinda spoken for when it comes to
land agreements armed with a trillion
dollars in cash though burns attempts to
just purchase the country from its
president Fidel Castro Castro proves to
be a little too cunning for burns though
he just asked to see the bill and then
pretends it was never handed to him with
that burns returns to the States
defeated but like most super-rich
criminals he never actually faces any
consequences two dozen and one
greyhounds from the sixth season of The
Simpsons is responsible for one of the
better toe tappers in the show's long
musical history it's also one of Burns's
most evil acts to date especially if
you're an animal lover you gotta admit
it's catchy when the Simpson family dog
Santa's Little Helper gets a little
frisky with another greyhound the family
finds themselves the proud yet
overwhelmed owners of 25 puppies
although they make a valiant effort to
care for the dogs they're forced to sell
them as they debate letting and oddly
interested burns take the whole litter
the devious tycoon steals them when
their backs are turned
fortunately Bart and Lisa tracked them
down at burns Manor and hear him singing
his plans to make the dogs into a tuxedo
it turns out he's been making clothes
from adorable animals for years that's
bad enough to merit inclusion on a list
of his worst acts but doing in two dozen
puppies for the sake of fashion is a new
level of evil fortunately Bart and Lisa
intervened before he can do his Grimm
tailoring job but Burns Holtz the two
kids at gunpoint in order to stop them
in the end Burns is convinced that he
shouldn't off the dogs and vows to never
wear the fur of another animal as long
as they can do an amusing trick
sorry Gophers this is a unique inclusion
on the list
it marks a rare occasion in which burns
doesn't revel in his villainy instead
his bad behavior merely comes from a
deeply misguided place after a series of
bad investments causes burns to lose his
vast fortune the episode the old man and
the Lisa sees him forced to live the
life of an average Joe even shacking up
with Smithers for a brief period however
his quest to find fulfillment as an
impoverished elderly person is
short-lived
as his life quickly spirals out of
control and lands him in the retirement
castle when Lisa Simpson comes around on
a crusade to increase Springfield's
recycling Byrnes decides to mend his
previously greedy ways by attempting to
give back it seems like things are going
well as Lisa's desire to help the
environment meshes with Burns's business
acumen however upon the opening of the
little Lisa recycling plant burns
reveals that he strung together hundreds
of plastic 6-pack holders to sweep the
sea clean of both waste and marine life
in a horrific but very well animated
shot we see hundreds of animals being
dragged from the ocean and turned into a
meat slurry that burns then sells and
best of all it's made from 100% recycled
animals Lisa is obviously horrified much
to the confusion of Burns who genuinely
believes he merely took recycling to the
next level although this is by far one
of Burns's worst acts it's scary to
think that this kind of carnage is what
happens when he goes with his best
intentions instead of his worst check
out one of our newest videos right here
plus even more looper videos about your
favorite stuff are coming soon subscribe
to our YouTube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]